I believe important things are whether the product is really wanted,
and whether people willlike the service and keep using it.
We are the developers of Fril, a flea market app.
We discovered that many women
upload photos of clothes to their blogs to sell them.
We thought creating an app that made it easy to buy and sell clothes
might be a good business opportunity.
Most of our users are young women, such as college students and housewives.
Before release, we interviewed more than 100 women
to test our service.
We came up with our design by working with our users.
During development, we had users actually use our prototype.
And we tested it to make sure that users were able to use it in the way they expected.
We also used many interviews and surveys about the app's visual design
to find a design that users would like.
We've been using this approach since our company was founded,
helping instill a corporate culture where we create our service with the help of our users.
We introduced the new "Material Design" concept
during the development of the app
in a way that wouldn't affect the experience of existing users,
so our initial release was about 70% Material Design compliant.
The results were remarkable.
Our new user retention rate rose by 7%.
And time spent in app increased by an incredible 200%.
We hire our customer support staff from our user base,
so all of them use the app.
We use focus groups and user testing
whenever we consider adding features and to test new designs.
The designers themselves perform layout adjustments
using Android Studio.
It allows you to test using various devices while you're adjusting the design,
and it has features like code completion, which make it very easy for designers to use as well.
Since our app is used for buying and selling between individuals,
and you can even withdraw money with it,
encountering things like bugs can be a major problem.
The Developer Console for Android developers
has a feature that lets you release in stages,
so you can release an update 5% or 20% at a time,
and this lets you find out ahead of time if there are any bugs.
It's very convenient.
Ever since we became compliant with Google's Material Design,
our retention rate has increased by 20%
and our sign-up rate has increased by 30%.
Whether you have a product that people really want,
and whether they will like your service enough to keep using it are very important questions.
We created our company name "Fablic"
based on a combination of the words
"fab" (meaning fabulous) and "holic" (meaning addicted).
We want to live up to our name by making a service
that our users will really become addicted to.